my son's euro-step left hand jump sorry
dude he almost he actually almost beat
me in pop shop like Papa Schadt like
this already this weekend he scored 29
like he just J's where is he a lefty -
I'm trying to make just put everything
like Lucas right hand like like I'm like
really like [ __ ] like psycho dad yeah
he's only lefty only euro-step only
jumpshot and already completely brain
like his poor first grade class they all
know that'll never dunk because he got
it into his head and he's like there and
now he's just spitting it to them sure
I'm gonna hold like just baffled like
why can't we ever dunk it's just a wild
scene but it's like oh where I was going
like yeah like we need to do it because
you coming over and like shooting with
him like we'll be like oh he'll probably
knows he probably knows more about your
career than you do like all he does is
sit on 10 hours of iPad memorizing stats
of every hue it's I don't want to talk
to him about sports cuz he genuinely
knows more than me yeah he just his
whole life
alright what is it hey everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and this is episode
318 of the askgaryvee show
and this is an episode i've been waiting
for for a long long time not only do I
admire this man for what he does in his
profession but watching him evolved the
words that come out of his mouth over
the last two to three years has been
inspiring to me it's really endeared me
to him I've really enjoyed the tons of
banter over the last 18 months we've
done on DM I super love dapping him up
on the court garden and he also like
guaranteed that they were gonna win and
everything was okay with two minutes to
go and then that's what happened I've
just been watching him a lot admire him
love a lot about him and looking forward
to getting to know him much more on my
personal level but wanted to give him
the platform and the opportunity you
know I got really excited the other day
with somebody outside like a lot and we
didn't get the phone calls I promise I'm
gonna stay very committed we will get
the calls in so if you're watching right
now on on Instagram we're gonna take the
call the numbers from YouTube and
Facebook YouTube Facebook have you got a
question for Kevin Love who is our guest
today
extraordinary MBA talent but on
believably exciting emerging voice for
many things that I'm passionate about in
society is our guests if you have
questions for him about anything that we
talked about please put your phone
number and a little bit of a preview of
your question Andy will be picking them
put it into YouTube or Facebook
I know Instagram I know you guys are
watching and I know that's where most
people are watching so I highly
recommend you switching over to Facebook
and YouTube for your questions if you
are passionate of keb thanks for being
on me it's been a long time coming it's
super long time coming back I begin -
anything else
I love origin stories like comic book
number one spit the three or four
minutes of like who you are Who am I
well I grew up in a basketball family I
heard you talking about your son six
years old the ball was placed in my hand
at a very early age I had a father who
came from Inglewood California went to
Morningside high school you know Byron
Scott Lisa Leslie went to the University
of Oregon played in the league for five
years was around my uncle who was in
rock and roll
Michael of the Beach Boys so he had a
little bit of he got to play for the LA
Lakers and the summer times got to
travel around with the Beach Boys but
best life ever
it's probably what he told me lasted
like four or five years that was
probably yeah before stars he was I
think it was 71 he was drafted ninth by
the 9th by the Baltimore bullets yeah
and actually on his draft card it said
good jumper for a white guy no way I
didn't have that 71 to the book that was
big-time teams as a big Western so my
middle name Western is Wesley after
Western so yes Carla pearl exactly and
then he played on I mean played with uh
I'm sorry think on the Lakers Connie
Hawkins Gail Goodrich Elmore Smith block
17 shots in a game Connie Hawkins is one
of the most interesting all-time
basketball players ever well his story
once about origin stories dr. Jay
basically cosines him as like I'm dr.
James Connie Hawkins no he was he was
basically MJ or dr. Jay before those
guys I mean he was a guy my dad used to
tell me he would pick it off the ground
either hand go up and it was I mean just
put it down he was yeah unbelievable so
it was like it was destiny from the gate
for you pretty much yeah like I said the
ball was
always loved always land I was the kid
I'm ever telling my best friend's dad he
likes to tell the story of me coming
back from my first day we live right
across the street from each other and he
would say you know what do you want to
be when you grow up I said I'm gonna be
in the NBA it was just so matter of fact
that you know I taught myself or I
really spoke it into existence he is a
dad didn't laugh at that the same way
given the DNA right given the DNA he was
around those teams when we were young in
Portland where was Rick Adelman was the
coach and Terry Porter the dock monster
was only yeah for sure Robinson yep
Terry Porter you understand why I know
those teams so well so literally the
human that I hate the most on earth is
Michael Jordan like number one on my
list Brady's a close second sir um and
that's completely predicated my jets I
was gonna say like I don't understand
Nick fans in their 40s that like MJ I
really don't I genuinely don't know I
don't understand it i tormented you guys
for years over there I don't understand
like respect is different right please
let there be no confusion I understand
who the player was mm-hmm
but like [ __ ] that right so you don't
know how much I love those Pistons
excuse me those those blazer teams
because I prayed to God that they could
flow yeah in the finals and yeah all
those times they faced them but it's
interesting to me you talk about MJ like
how same thing with bran like what guys
would have taken that next step
see the funny things easy guys well it's
funny it's funny and obviously played
with him like I love bran mainly because
the day I heard of him when he was like
[ __ ] 16 immediately no different than
Felipe Lopez which went in a different
direction sir or anybody else that even
begins a conversation of a chance to be
better than MJ like my heart and soul
I've never when you guys want that title
like I hate every team but mine sure but
that win against Golden State was
probably the most excited I've been for
any other team but mine because I knew
that it would add momentum to getting
the debate with LeBron MJ that I knew
how big of a historic win that would be
shoes for the debate yeah and it was
unprecedented
I mean I could remember speaking of
stories I can remember
were in Oakland we went to their
practice facility the Golden State
Warriors and it was the one you know
play head start Thompson started talking
about how they were better than the
Showtime Lakers and no that was kind of
a shot of his dad as well I grew up with
class so we're going over the the Bay
Bridge and that commentary is just still
picking up it's on Twitter it's on
Instagram it's on all these social
platforms a sports radio everything's
and that's when bran just said he looked
around it goes you know what guys this
is it's written we're gonna win tomorrow
night we're gonna have a huge game it's
gonna be tough yeah it's gonna come down
to the last few minutes we're not losing
at home Game seven anything can happen
that's how it played out it's crazy it
still gives me chills thinking about it
the crazy part back we're gonna bounce
back high level but were super narrow I
had to go to can in France which is the
big market it's like the Super Bowl for
marketing companies I was on the flight
to toucan during that game seven and
literally not for some reason everybody
went on Wi-Fi but for some reason my
phone because I don't have a laptop sure
like my phone was getting the update
play-by-play on ESPN faster by like a
tenth of a second than everybody else
around me and everybody was like and
it's overnight and you gotta get sleep
because the next day in France for the
next day and you gotta go
nobody sleep there's nothing like sport
and literally like standing like like it
was insane to play that whole fourth
quarter on your phone getting update by
update by update and by the way a lot of
the people I go to Canada from San
Francisco tech companies and all that
sure by the way on the record
ninety-eight percent of warrior fans are
straight [ __ ] bandwagon big shout out
to Jim lands own for CBS Interactive
you're the one true [ __ ] Warriors fan
that I know all you [ __ ] at Facebook
and Google and uber you [ __ ]
didn't even know Golden State was in San
Francisco a decade ago I was there [ __ ]
you you don't know if Mitch Richmond
took a [ __ ] on your face you wouldn't
know who he was so get the [ __ ] out of
here with your [ __ ] bandwagon fandom
and you're raising a little Chris Mullin
to so they don't know [ __ ] Tim
Hardaway Christmas they don't know what
they don't know anything about that [ __ ]
so anyway a little a little pent up
Knicks anger to start this [ __ ] cap go
way back so you're playing and you're
just good always weren't always good I
was always I was always big and we
talked about it before we came on like
I was a big kid yeah size mattered but I
always had the skill like my dad had the
foresight to know where the game was
going he put the ball in my hands wanted
me to play all five positions but he
also wanted me to shoot from Diaz like I
think my dad was ahead of his time he
was he was he is six nine and he was
about 210 pounds 205 pounds I was you
know six nine to 80 at one point and no
he was he was really ahead of his time
he could sit again like when you were
fat right which was I was just the
glutton for the sake of being a glutton
it was it wasn't like I had anything in
particular the other way and say like
all these people think I'm out of shape
I'm just gonna go even worse and still
ball on them yeah I don't actually
understand that after so I was uh I was
take on this whole issue Naismith
actually was a little subtle brag here
and not so subtle I was natural athlete
of the year my senior year looked at me
it would just stun you it would stun you
yeah you would look into this I wish
social media was further along back then
I think you would have made some
ridiculous content like hundred percent
just dumb like fifteen-year-old [ __ ] for
sure yeah cuz I have no shame in that
stuff like especially now you talk about
I apologize but that's where we're about
to go like I think some of the things
you're talking about like when you start
to talk about mental health issues and
other things you've talked about when I
watch you from afar I'm like that's
really good parenting really good DNA
and really good circumstance cuz that
kid is not insecure we have insecure
well that's right that's the
manifestation of sure so like there's
the things back to your weight maybe you
weren't insecure about that people
thought yeah clearly there were things
you were insecure about we all are for
sure but this is the manifestation of
you evolving to closing the gaps in
certain parts of your insecurities yeah
and you're so susceptible to change
early on that's why I think with
anything mental health-related whether
it be you know cuz I have a saying you
know kill the body and the mind eyes
like so many kids early on now are just
killing their bodies just to the extent
of I mean you're seeing more look good
to be a good athlete to have like ripped
like all the everything it transcends
yeah no it's really crazy kids are
picking up weights earlier on to load on
their body they're specializing in sport
earlier on that I have no problem with
that I played basketball in baseball
there came a point in time where my dad
was like
you're gonna be what Randy Johnson
you're not left-handed you don't have a
mole it you know you it's just not gonna
be new I could [ __ ] rock a good mole
and I would be like a David wells where
I'd probably pitch hungover and do a
perfect game you know like and I'd be in
a Yankee uniform and that would be
incredible but your point right like how
you know literally I said this I spoke
to the Rutgers football team this
morning and one of the things I was
talking to when the coaches on the way
out is literally this is not a joke and
this is me really Metta I've been
thinking a lot about like this question
I get asked a lot which is like what
business if I like much like I started
vaynermedia when I was done with the
wine thing and like just literally
started at scratch and it was left field
for me to build this come from the wine
world yeah what business would I start
and I can't stop thinking about this one
thing the number one business as of this
moment that I would start in the world
is something in you that let excision
the not that 99.9 percent of parents
that are listening to this podcast right
now are so [ __ ] delusional that they
think their kid is going to the league
when they have no prayer like America
your kid is not playing shortstop in
baseball pay attention
like what is the matter with you sir
like literally I'm like oh I'm gonna
build a [ __ ] billion dollar business
exploiting the fact that people are
taking kids that will never play college
sports and training them like they're
gonna be [ __ ] LeBron right delusion
delusion and that's why a lot of kids
are going to early to one sport because
their mom and dad are saying if you want
to get to the league we need to decide
down instead of kids being happy and
rounded their parents are [ __ ]
brainwashing them they're gonna be on
the [ __ ] World Cup soccer team but
they have to give up football basketball
for night happiness and [ __ ]
everything else meanwhile that kid sucks
no really and I mean it I want to use
sucks because I'm hoping one parent
listens like actually you know what that
might be true ya know I have no problem
with saying that I'm I'm with you on
that I'm tired of all these
participation trophies people you know
families I think their their kids are
that good listen I I believe that youth
sports is a great way to transition into
life because it teaches you people
skills it teaches you how to be a leader
or a follower or being able to follow
then turning into many different things
and it's a ways you in two different
really a lot of difference all of those
it's its it teaches you a number of
things by not letting kids leave exactly
and it's it's terrible I was just at the
Aspen ideas conference and we had talked
about that there was a lot a lot of
scales out there and I imagine those are
the parents that oh are the ones that
you're talking about went to it's like
two brilliant minds in Stockholm it was
super fancy yeah and I went out there
and gave a ten minute straight from the
hip first time talk around entitlement
and let me promise you what went through
everybody's mind yeah I suck because you
can't over dope because we're raising
zoo animals right like listen I wish I
was in the league you think I want to
sit courtside and watch you I want to
[ __ ] play but self-awareness kicked
in I would foul this [ __ ] yeah I would
yeah
I actually would I returned into oak and
I was just 94 Knicks now like like
there's guys that play with me here like
I'm trying to hurt people in pickup get
yeah now yeah my own employees and
friends like like me me and AJ my
brother can't play in the same team and
our pickup games anymore because within
the first 30 seconds everyone's on tilt
so you basically created your own Jordan
rules for the people that you work with
they come in there's like you know I'm
sorry I don't know the demographic I'm
assuming it's a lot of young people
watch me have no idea that Jordan often
was positioned in the mid to late 80s as
never having a chance to win a
championship never gonna get through the
Pistons are where to go this and that
and like literally some of my last
enjoyable moments was watching like
clotheslining Jordan you know Pistons
sweep like I love that they walk I know
that they get [ __ ] on for walking off
after the Bulls finally got through them
sir
I love it [ __ ] him let him have no
enjoyment anyway nonetheless let's not
get sidetracked too much let's we've
been alluding to it obviously you you
have this great career you let's talk
about for five seconds your recruitment
to where you played college ball because
I have a really funny story that I think
I might have once told you on DM or a
call I don't know if I've gone to a
significant
college basketball game in the last 15
years it's just the nature of how busy I
am but ironically oh my gosh Atari I
hope you're listening or watching right
now I made real good friend of mine who
worked at CIA took me to a UCLA game
like somehow in this one weird window I
went to a game and it was your freshman
year I remember like watch it playing I
don't recall I don't want to [ __ ] it
but uh but I just recall like the three
and three of you were standing out to me
you know Carlson and Russ and I remember
like that like he was super pumped he's
like these [ __ ] freshmen they're
gonna be [ __ ] awesome they're gonna
make a real run in the tournament I cuz
I'm so busy get like I the one thing I
mandate at vaynermedia is that every
employee fills out a bracket for March
Madness and then the winner gets a huge
prize it's like a company-wide thing I'm
[ __ ] crazy about it but I'm so busy
um I'm headlined reading for my pics and
I remember that Omid brainwashed me
about you and your crew so I had you
guys going super [ __ ] far like I
think I had you losing in the finals so
I was super pissed when you guys
underperformed so there's that however
let's talk about how you got to UCLA
like was it always them was there like
always always them there's something
weird happened I'm fascinated by the
recruit so yeah you go back to the
origin story here to back up my dad
actually played at Morningside high
school gym Heric
the great Jim Herrick was his assistant
coach at Morningside high school so they
would play one-on-one they go back and
forth and you know then those great
teams like the 95 national championship
team yet though abandon brothers Tyus
Edney with what 4.8 seconds to get to
the Final Four so UCLA was lost to
Princeton or the year before I'm
confusing I'm not I'm not so all I
remember is I picked Princeton in my
bracket and they stunned him yeah that
guy was a hero you were the guy yeah
that's like the Richmond spiders upset
that I picked against Q spiders from
your high school I wrote it on the
blackboard before every class I mean Q's
always finds a way I said Jim Boeheim
they always yeah I was kidding
the so you were always destined to go
there I feel like I was I mean Oregon
was always in my backyard I always
always considered it a little bit
always and Nike I mean it was just like
feel night I live everything if you're
from Oregon that's everything I'm like
football and my dad went to university
Oregon so that was I
go into the football games I grew up
going to those it was close between
North Carolina where's Roy Williams and
they had just come off winning a
national championship a couple years
prior was that a part of you doing [ __ ]
like hey it might be cool to be on the
East Coast I've always been a West Coast
kid and it was the Duke and UNC where I
was yeah the ACC was unbelievable but
you know UCLA I've been to two straight
Final Fours at the time Ben Howland was
you know very good at teaching his guys
and having his guys go to the next level
and have success and I think that
continued remind me remind me where we
were in the high school coming straight
out of high school versus two years
removed from I think what 2000 right
five was the last year just had to go
but I probably would have gone anyway
yes flat out flat out did you
fundamentally know you're gonna be one
and done yes always new one yeah it was
no secret so they came down to UCLA and
North Carolina and finally Kerry Keating
whose assistant coach there at the time
still heavily involved in California not
only athletics but basketball as well he
just said you know are we doing this I
remember I was at a tournament in Vegas
where they have you know the 500 team
you play five to five games on [ __ ]
Sunday the win yeah I found the right
moment I was like okay you got me
committed to UCLA I ended up going that
was my rising senior year end up going
to UCLA and you know made best friends
with Russell Westbrook and we just
talked about how we were going to the
NBA every single day four and five pick
pretty cool we're roommates it's real
cool yeah real cool so what's the you
know just there's a random question cuz
I really want to get into somebody off
the court stop what was the biggest
surprise of you had a dad that was in
league your groom for this you know the
pedigree
it's [ __ ] 24/7 even when it wasn't
it's running in the background what was
the biggest surprise there is nothing
you can do to prepare for the speed the
speed the grind but playing against in
Texas against Dirk or Tim Duncan flying
back home on a back-to-back
in Minnesota and playing kg in the
Boston Celtics and there's just nothing
you can do
you're playing two games a week in
college in the tournament you're playing
that you know Thursday Saturday Thursday
Sunday and then you wait to the next
week and then you go to the you know
sweet 16 elite a Final Four right so not
only is the volume and speed of which
the games come at you it's also palettes
and we we had so I mean we had lottery
picks we had you know guys that were
first rounders guys that have huge
success in the league in the pac-10 of
time pac-12 now but there's nothing you
can do to emulate that I played Dirk and
yeah Tim Duncan within the first five
games of my career a Tony Parker put up
55 points on us I'm like this is the NBA
so I got five minutes away from playing
like a video game with Tony Parker and
like he's not hundred percent yeah yeah
exactly and like I'm poor that's what we
did is we played video games all the
time in our locker room at UCLA I'm like
you know I'm a pic you know bran and
okay I'm gonna pick you know the Lakers
I'm gonna be Kobe and then you're you
get there and it's like okay Kobe's
putting 40 on us every single time and
there's nothing you can do he'll tell
you to right straight to your face yes
you guys don't have a chance tonight is
Friday night and on the show who's I'm
going who's who's uh who's the one
player that you like warm you know tuck
it in you're checking in you get on the
court and then you actually see him and
it was like actually the biggest
response you had whether it was
something funny an inside joke because
you remember being at a camp or whether
it was Kobe and you're like [ __ ] this is
actually Kobe it's not how do person
yeah Kobe cuz there's this I mean I've
and this is no disrespect to Bron
because he brings them out to and he
there's that energy in the gym and
everybody's best game is your whole
mindset shifts to when you become a you
get on a team like that I mean we were a
super team and we were a team that was
expected go the finals expected to have
the potential to win a championship yeah
but when I first got into the league
Kobe Bryant it didn't matter if it was a
soft Tuesday in Minneapolis Kobe's
bringing them out yeah I mean there's a
there's a buzz in the city that Kobe is
there and like and like the worst part
which I still want to punch every person
in the building when I'm there like Kobe
drops the first bucket it's two nothing
Lakers that Minnesota
and 73% of the audience is cheering oh
no it was a violent oh and there's a
it's a Minneapolis Lakers it's a home
game for but I mean it's like everywhere
they went because like a to nothing when
coach jump shot I'm like Ronning dat
back down the court like trying to argue
with fans like [ __ ] leave right
I hate visiting fans when I go to
visiting games as a Jets fan I don't say
a word
I'm trying to think of who you would who
you would what's like looking in a
mirror for you and they sleep to the
test meets but like whatever the worst
things that I've ever happened in sports
yeah that that okay because I'm like so
you are like a speaking of Randy Johnson
in the sea a tomorrow you were like a
Lou Pinella you take out the bass and
you I throw this [ __ ] is not unlike in
business people like steal a million
dollars for me I'm like and that's why I
have to be careful to not project maybe
what I hate about being a fan is I'm not
in control you know they can be there
like when I'm in control like to see how
this company everything bad easy
maybe I'm just frustrated as a fan like
[ __ ] like you know like right like maybe
that's what it is so maybe I actually am
completely full of [ __ ] it's completely
the other way when I would actually be
on the corridor field but no cuz when we
play I'm like crazy so speaking out of
control though I don't like when you're
not like here's my thought when you're
not he's been begging me this whole time
to come out and play some ball like I'm
always scared because while you're still
what a retire will be easier okay get
weird and like like then it's like on
like then people actually found out the
real story if you like feeling [ __ ]
like I'm always like I invite jet
players I'm where we hang and likes
others with I'm like [ __ ] I better be
careful here cuz actually I'm gonna be
taking HGH and testosterone at that time
average fits and just go after you let's
jump to it cuz I don't want it to get
away from us let's talk about some of
the things you've been talking about
sure there's some of things you're
passionate about because I think it's
uncomfortably important and I think
you've you're building momentum just
like I think about so many people that
have brought so much value whether it's
Curt Flood or Jackie Robinson you know
what color barrier or sort just all
these things you know watching some of
stuff Kyle Korver's talking about I'm
just I'm really excited about
what I believe you and a couple others
have started the momentum conversation
for a lot of people that don't even know
where I'm going
set it up for me and give me the context
tell me the backstory yeah it's I mean
everything that you're alluding to is
mental health related I've dealt with
only panic attacks but anxiety and
depression my entire life it's just
something that I've always always dealt
with I suffered silently until I was 29
years old I had an in-game panic attack
against the Atlanta Hawks on November
5th it was a scary moment a lot of a lot
of been going just devastatingly wrong
in my life in that last pillar to fall
was basketball that was always your safe
place I was always my safe place success
it was a place it's escapism everybody's
looking for their escape
I work his mind - exactly you work it
and and you know for some people it can
be whatever their vices it could be
drugs and alcohol so I can be you know
exhausting their body like Robin
Williams that was it for him yep
yeah with Kate Spade who ended up taking
her life that was it was her work yeah
you know is everything that she stood
for and her image
yeah and that was a big reason that she
ended up you know not coming out and
saying what she dealt with because she
was asked afraid what I was gonna do for
her Brandon managed but so I didn't gain
panic attack it was a really scary
moment for me I've talked at length
about it where I actually thought I was
having cardiac arrest and I was I was
you know looking for something that
wasn't there I'd always had places to go
like I wasn't kidding about the rage
fits like I know I said testosterone all
that [ __ ] I'm done playing but when I
was young that's how it manifested
because I didn't really know how I was
feeling
I didn't know I knew what the the
depression was more so like I wouldn't
come out of bed for two weeks I would
play my basketball and I would go into
my room I'm not like my brother would
say it was funny a couple weeks after I
had written the players Tribune article
and discussed that everybody's going
through something he was like oh yeah we
would just just wait for you to be Kevin
again but straight up two weeks oh yeah
no I had had moments where it had been
there's little triggers here and there
where I've developed a new relationship
with with both my anxiety and depression
but it was uh it could last months at a
time you last months at a time
so I dealt with that that's one thing if
it's overlaying it's another thing if
you're like physically
[ __ ] herself in a room for two weeks
yeah you know I would go in there
everybody here is walking on earth yeah
with pressures sure anxieties concerns
doubts yeah
and you'll find ways to hide it like my
best friends didn't even know like I
would I would hide how do they not know
cab in a two week like that's where I'm
actually going like how would a best
friend not know that you're locked up in
two weeks or are you saying every moment
I had that I didn't have to go to school
or practice run to the room are you
saying two weeks I'm out and like I made
pretend I was sick
basically I mean there were times where
I either wouldn't go to school or you
know in class I would just be like super
quiet and everybody has their moments
with their friends their girlfriends at
that time there's nothing like you know
young love that corner sort of thing but
no this was you seem super young and
loved these days oh yeah I'm chasing
that a little I just when you travel in
Caleb's in space but probably the most
romantic Graham right now it's about me
I mean me and Kate or me oh my god yes
you I don't know I know I know but like
if I'm a puppy biggest fan of dogs no no
you and that's another part yeah that's
a whole but go ahead
no so it's super cute yeah it's it's
good for my mental health
I believe it no it really is I believe
in the travelling and the wine yes but
no I think no I came to a point where I
was just I was done suffering silently
for you I mean I had such terrible
balance my depression I missed a Hawks
game like was it I'm starting to
remember like subtle things but I don't
I can't drill it like everybody knew
like what happened nobody knew that's
what that so that was that's the
craziest part so yeah let me back up so
what do you get out of the game yeah so
it was after halftime and we were down
we lose it to the Hawks and I mean let's
just call it the Hawks except the
hospital they're good now I understand
so we were like they were like three and
nine at the time I mean you go look it
up though
it was really really not great and so
basketball was the last moment resting
it on yourself oh yeah my worst yeah
myself talk terribly it's me yeah it's
me and everything is going wrong and I
have no escape now I'm supposed to be
this guy for this team yeah like I'm the
berry Bowl craziest part about it was I
was all started I was named to the all
sorts I know who you are
so I remember or like actually I want to
throw out a compliment real quick cuz I
just [ __ ] thought of it right now I
back to like my life got real busy the
Knicks have not necessarily been so
exciting and unlike the Jets on Sundays
it's been hard for me to follow the
Knicks last 25 years the way I want to
now I've gotten to a place where I can
afford this summer didn't help either no
dude I'm on so tilt I don't want to go
down I've got a screen shot right now me
FaceTime with KD I don't know if I've
ever recruited anything harder that I
feel Katy I'm so sorry for the last
month of what I put you through I know
everybody put you through [ __ ] but I
[ __ ] brought it I gave it my whole
heart I remember you [ __ ] went crazy
early on your career in Minnesota
against the Knicks in one rant I wasn't
catching a lot of games but that's 31
and 31 yes that was at home yeah I will
I was like oh and because I saw you as a
kid like in that game it was just like
it's just I was like holy [ __ ] this
guy's real real real good like I was
like whoa this guy's way better than I
thought like you [ __ ] went crazy and
hit like a late with a game-winner and I
won or like super late three yeah so I
think I had 28 points and 31 rebounds at
the time I hit a three and that put us
ahead yes I remember yeah anyway that
was like literally a standout game for
me all time yeah like one of the more
uncomfortably good performances I
watched I guess yeah I guess when yeah
it's all relative when you're talking
about thirty thirty-one is [ __ ] no
[ __ ] yeah I guess it is anything but it
just happened to be your chance a team
that's like that Sixers for four years
ago 31 and 31 is uncomfortable yeah how
many [ __ ] people that broke up 31 31
I bet you it's less than ten I think
before that it was uh Moses Malone yeah
yeah so anyway nonetheless it happened
half-time yeah have a suck [ __ ] [ __ ]
this oh and then and then it be
the cycle right like yeah [ __ ] is this
gonna happen to the one place that I've
been able to protect what yeah right so
that's why I go back to the rage fist
like when I was when I was young that's
how it used to manifest and then I had
nowhere always had somewhere to go like
I go to my room or I'd go and you know
break the video game system or something
like that yeah so no I went I just was
like I have nowhere to go there's 23,000
people watching and that even made it
worse so my heart is speeding up and I'm
thinking I'm having like a cardiac
arrest like in my whole body shed with a
trainer so I go to my I run I'm running
around the locker room nobody's there I
go straight to my my head trainer Steven
Spiros office I just fall on the ground
I pass out out like I'm gasping for I'm
sticking my hand literally down my
throat like I'm thinking like
something's dislodged in there I'm
trying to get some out and I mean it was
like a full-on [ __ ] panic I'm gonna
die I don't know what's happening full
sweats from the game and this is it
this is the moment so I ended up going
to the you know they they got me back
they had me on oxygen they sent me to
the Cleveland Clinic to run some tests
everything checked out and then at that
point I was just kind of like what the
[ __ ] just happened
you knew yeah why I had an idea so that
that I forget what day the game was on
but that was right before the first time
I was like okay I'm gonna see a
therapist good for you and when did it
when from there did you write the
article not until March because yeah
there was still so much going on I tried
to hide it for so long yeah I didn't go
through my process so then how many
peopIe apologize cause I'm looking at
time I knew you guys have a hard stop so
I'm going off of that like how many
people reached out to you privately
after that article that forget about
fans well I didn't know what to expect
cuz my agent was like alright so your
everybody there's gonna be big I said
maybe you know like but I'm tired of
suffering silently like I want to play
all my cards and fast-forward it now
like I'm so much more comfortable in my
own skin just I'm like this just what
you get and like you know I heard you
talk about the other day like what's
your North Star like happiness is my
North Star but that's ambiguous for
everybody
it's it's not defined as a
one-size-fits-all model that's right
like so I'm actually the number one
compounding at scale on Instagram I have
the youths attention like money can't be
it no actually isn't for almost
everybody no it isn't and everybody
thinks I'm not saying that money like
money is a great enabler of things and a
great currency sure but it's not the
only currency that matters for us now
like it's it's time how much time you
have it's like Oh elasticity like
between money and time like time is our
biggest commodity and so that's how I'm
trying to I'm trying to figure out you
laughed about my Instagram's like how am
I trying to spend my time and so I'm
trying so much more now to just I'm
pressing sand on [ __ ] I'm like I don't
care what people think of this I'm
trying to spend positive anything it
really makes me happy real soon I mean
like if people are like oh [ __ ] I'm
going to get out there and truly
everybody looks there's a lot of
attractive people hanging out with each
other on Instagram it just as obvious to
me that it's happy that's not I don't
know why but I'm not joking I'm not just
like its authenticity it took me so long
to feel all the way there and I'm feel
like I'm getting there but how many
superstars athletes celebrities ping you
privately after the article I mean the
the number of it was probably I think we
got like eighty-five hundred emails
within the first three days and I was I
was saying I was like alright you guys
have to email me here so that I can try
and get back to and respond to everybody
and then the number just became so
outrageous and you know entertainers and
athletes and music it was I mean it
crazy in that hundreds four or 500 but
mostly it was I would say the the large
number why he became into the the triple
digits was because it was athletes and
even Adam Silver's as said every level
as said now I heard seven-year-olds oh
yeah a lot of football players to
getting that see getting hit in the head
a lot of football players and any myths
that are not there yet they're right you
know you start becoming scared of it
yeah I think it's well guys a retired
now 25 aj derrick Mort exactly I don't
know if you saw what he wrote like the
proudest thing that has happened in my
world that I haven't said out loud is we
signed Derek Morgan to Boehner Sports
made him more money
the field and all the things that banner
sports brings to football players and we
didn't make a penny and we knew we
weren't gonna make a penny because it
was highly cuz we knew he was too
thoughtful and worried about it that he
would sign another contract so we worked
with him for two years in the NFL
whoever does the contract gets the
dollars not whoever's the cards agent
and it makes me smile every day and it
makes me smile because I'm happy for him
yeah because if we were putting pressure
on him to sign one more deal so to make
us ROI positive but he took one or two
more hits than he wanted to [ __ ] if it
would have actually done something the
percept perceptions [ __ ] reality and
when stuff starts getting in your head
that way yeah I mean like I truly
believe to like you you get what you
give I didn't I didn't realize that like
that's why I think I'm settled into now
because I'm I think as an athlete you're
burning it at both ends so fast and so
quickly some longer than others have
spent depending on you know we could to
have a whole talk about longevity is
worse but you know it comes out too fast
I'm headed into my 12th season I was
just talking about how Tony Parker and I
was putting 55 on that I was playing KJ
and Dirk and all those guys but I now
feel like I have a higher purpose and
you know I can affect the masses just
makes me does that make you want to also
play your tomb or because the platform
is oh for sure he's for sure extensible
yeah post post basketball I feel like
I'm doing a good job of laying the
groundwork to stumble across in
Minnesota whether on your team or
somewhere else
that all of a sudden the last two or
three years you're like wait a minute
I'm old now like in that funny way that
we talk another and you're like wait a
minute my second year that [ __ ] old
dude that I now I understand why he like
threw the water at thing or why he was
in the corner yelling at back like wait
a minute that was [ __ ] I'm gonna do that
do you have anything like that no I mean
yes and there's I should write a book I
mean it's like Collin Sexton he's he's
19 years old I'm sitting there the
amount of Collin sex and rookie cards
Mike my son and I are picking up right
now cuz we think he's sneaky underrated
a sneaky underrated and he's here he's
here he's at basketball city this
morning talking to the kids I'm like
dude you're eight years older than these
guys five years older than these guys
yeah yeah he's like let me tell you what
I've learned in my career
yeah hey text me like you were here I
was like bro you're talking to these
kids you're the [ __ ] kid like you
just won yeah like a year removed
no but he's uh yes but that's the
craziest part about it like he's so
young he doesn't even like he's a lot of
untapped potential sneaky underrated as
you said but he's just so young and then
you look at guys like Dirk retiring this
year or or Vince Carter he's still going
he's never retiring you know that right
he's right no it's in perpetuity yeah
I'm surprised at Nixon sign him Jim are
you starting to rise no you're just I
mean the Knicks by the way on the record
I think the Knicks are blackballed on
the record I'm pretty convinced
intuitively there's no better place to
play right but but this offseason was
deeply uncomfortable from the way I
think about the world like that like the
real world is grey not black and white
sure I'm I'm in a very scary place of
fear never fear like even when the Jets
of Knicks have been at the worst there's
no math that makes sense they didn't get
any of the players which makes me go
into deep conspiracy theory the Oakley
thing top 50 players got into a weird
dinner decided and we're done that's
literally what I believe oh I hope it's
not true but I nothing makes sense like
you can't be in that spot where the
Clippers and Nets get through like they
had all the leverage all the math anyway
I don't even get the press like on that
in sports depression to put in context
of all people [ __ ] this let's definitely
do a call okay what is your favorite
sports team favorite sports so personal
like your team that you root for the
most so I grew up anybody I mean I grew
up watching it's funny I was like I was
a Niners fan because I was I grew up
perfect time to be yeah and also it was
right there and within the North West I
grew up in Portland Oregon and then I
was a Mariners guy because they you know
yeah everybody they've been good for you
sir yeah Jay Buhner
I mean Griffey junior baseball I hit the
cheek code and the Yankees made all time
all you know
was the man to Jay Buhner and he like
had that look before that look existed
they were bashing he was a beast who's a
beast they they like so to Edgar they
just got inducted but yesterday Edgar is
actually the only person that knew how
to hit Mariano Rivera ever yeah
like literally that's another that's a
nobody could hit the Carter nobody yeah
I'm going mad max it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and Kevin Love how are you good how are
you we are well what's your question my
question was can max really admit right
now you are stunned that you actually
got called and now your battle and you
have to come up with a question on the
spot I'm actually do you know what I
knew you're gonna ask this question
because I watch a ton of your stuff so I
knew you were gonna ask this question
and I knew it was gonna come up but I'm
actually kind of not good just got
watching the comment section yep I knew
that I was engaging with the people in
the comments enough this is a question
no no he's making a profound statement
of how he tricked Andy to call him good
[ __ ] max now what's the question yeah
Maxie you like go ahead ya know my
question was from like a management
perspective because I manage a lot of
different music artists so it's a little
bit out of the realm but I was wondering
I wanted to get your input on what is
the most effective way to deal with and
market talent to get it out to the
widest audience base got it so I'll jump
in real quick and then anything that'd
be fun the deal with part is impossible
because they're [ __ ] artists which
means they act like idiots often right
and what you need to remember but what
you need to remember is not to be a dick
because they have talent and you don't
and that's why you decided to manage
them make sense like
they don't want people are always trying
to like get artists to be like on time
that's not what they do they [ __ ]
write great songs they create great
beats they perform on stage like that's
so like I'm always laughing at my
manager friends they're like yo Gary yo
can you just talk to this kid I'm like
dude you love this kid because he
[ __ ] died his hair purple and [ __ ]
one minute of sleep can go out in front
of 40,000 people at rolling loud and
[ __ ] slay it not because he shows up
on time for a meeting with me dick right
so exactly so I think you need to
[ __ ] own what you decided to do for a
living and understand you got to take
the good with the bad
that's how you deal with it you don't
dwell on what they suck at you [ __ ]
focus on what they're phenomenal at as
far as getting them out there it's
called [ __ ] SoundCloud and Instagram
and YouTube and I Spit it 40 times a day
all the time
put [ __ ] music out the end the same
advice it was a pure content play yes
you're in the content business every
[ __ ] artist ever sucked until they
put a banger out exactly like everybody
sucked until they put out a song that
made them not suck Alanis Morissette
nobody knew
killed it you understand it's as simple
as that and now that you've SoundCloud
and [ __ ] Spotify and YouTube there's
no more ANR's
and [ __ ] MTV and [ __ ] the labels it's
like no [ __ ] excuses get in studio
make a song put it out DM a thousand
influencers hope somebody shares it
[ __ ] then let the market decide like
I know everybody gets mad at me for
saying like the same advice it's the
right advice it's like how you got into
better shape exercise and eating right
sorry
sorry that's what it is you would you
would you do the same thing is like with
a clothing brand with the musical artist
as far as the influencers go like would
you paint and influence yes shoes yes
but but everything needs exposure so
yeah you know either you're so great
that Sports Illustrated puts you in it
and you get exposure or or not and like
yes I would pay but you also need to be
good everything comes back down to merit
like I understand how to try to become a
basketball player which is like work
all these skills but if I wasn't
physically inclined to have it it would
mean that I'd be a good AAA I'd be a
good like pickup basketball player and
that's what I tell people about clothing
brands like yes you should overpay you
should pay influencers to rock your [ __ ]
but if your shits whack or if you
overpaid the influencer your skills in
it weren't good enough so like it's not
a one-size-fits-all advice it's be great
at influencer marketing there's a reason
that vaynermedia does the work for Fela
and feel it did get rebooted because
we're the best at the [ __ ] world at
what we do there's a reason that
everybody wants to say they have a
fashion brand as an entrepreneur on
Instagram because they printed a
thousand t-shirts but being a successful
fashion brand versus printing 90 shirts
and calling yourself a brand because you
came up with a funny sentence those are
two very different things
and there's a lot of [ __ ] on
instagram with funny sentence t-shirt
companies yeah execution bro I mean
thank you and I'm lucky at the time you
got a bro how do you think about fashion
you like it I see you wearing a [ __ ]
stone Colt yeah how do you think about
it you like it yeah I love fashion and
plus I mean it's it's become a huge
thing and in in basketball especially
would come playoff time I mean these
guys boy from college I mean he's yeah
if created a second I think Russ is just
making sure I feel like he sometimes
trolling the game like he loves fashion
but some of this [ __ ] I'm like you know
what we're sure but he knows what's
gonna get eyes it's just like you said
it's gonna create content and
everybody's everybody is gonna send him
so much stuff to try to influence their
brand I couldn't become a runway it has
become a business he's great yeah he's
really really gonna end it oh my god can
you imagine what between PJ Tucker Russ
and James Harden what that's gonna be
like gap hey javi how's it going guys
good man say what's up to K LOVE hey
Kevin it was good buddy hey actually uh
my question is I heard you talking about
you know being depression and having
anxiety attacks and stuff so my question
to you is that how to stay strong
and like they focused on your goals
while you going through that yeah I mean
that's that's super I mean that's
probably the toughest part because a lot
of the time I mean for me it was
basically having blinders on and not
seeing the effect I was having not only
on myself but other people and I also
read like a cheap novel like everybody
knows what I'm really going through it
but I would always say you know if for
me it was chasing basketball I was
chasing my vice it was chasing what I
love and I always feel like if you chase
what you love everything you love will
chase you right back everything you want
out of this life but you know you you
have to find ways to manage it
especially you know at your worst times
and a lot of people can't afford a
therapist they can't afford you know
going to see someone and paying for that
so you have to find tools whether it be
meditation whether it be exercising
getting that you know endorphin release
you know finding ways to deal with your
serotonin levels whether it be
medication I've noticed a lot of kids
hitting me up about eating like eating
behaviors changed eating eating changes
everything I just wants me to like like
him and his dad who's like some crazy
Turkish like genius yeah we're about
like I'm about to go there soon on I'm
getting I told you to back a card I'm
ready I could take all my blood like I'm
ready I'm not the [ __ ] change it up
you can check you can change your life
like your relationship with your body I
feel like is is so so key I mean I know
that I filming something but I've lost
so much weight I've kept the
inflammation down in my body I think
chronic inflammation like I've seen it
in my father I've seen in a ton of
people I've seen it in retired athletes
I've seen it in we've mentioned football
players where they were retired or not
like when you feel like [ __ ]
getting out of bed every day in the
morning you're like this day's gonna
suck this day's gonna be terrible pains
bad yeah pain management well that's
what exactly but you know I would just
say yeah finding different ways ways to
manage it and finding different ways to
change the relationship with whether it
be your anxiety depression or any any
phase of mental illness I'm a type of
person that medication has worked for me
has yes keep going
you know cognitive behavioral therapy is
work for me as well and you know science
and data has showed that you
that can actually prove to be more
beneficial over time than meds so but
you'll get back to the therapist part
for a sec this can be a friend this can
be you know listening to your podcast
finding ways to deal with other [ __ ]
deal with business deal with anything
that you're into it could be a family
member it can be you know somebody who
you know a parent of you know one of
your your kids friends you know it can
be anybody within arm's distance it's a
place where I tread very lightly cuz I
like talking about [ __ ] I know yeah and
so take it for what it's worth Gavin I
think one thing that I've seen a ton of
messages from is finding somebody who's
a little bit further away from your
inner circle so it doesn't affect that
dynamic has been really fascinating how
people think I've never thought about
before you know like when it's your mom
or your brother over time that can
create something within that dynamic and
having the luxury of it being a little
but you know if you think about a
therapist a step removed or three steps
removed sure like friend a friend or
acquaintance it's been real and maybe
that person will it comes from an
unbiased point of view it's not gonna
ruin your relationship exactly like
there's just so many other variables
yeah that's what and that's why the
therapists so far removed has such value
you know they'll probably catch
something else um being able to afford
it how does it you know sometimes one
kid wrote me this man if it I love
reading my comments and learned so much
insights that I'm not going through this
kid talked about something of me talking
about like not over judging yourself it
led him to another thing then he read
something about something out what it
led to was it being a teacher in his
school that he doesn't even has as a
teacher sure you know he found it as a
removed thing like it really worked and
I was like oh that's you know when you
think about the DNA of a teacher they
want to help right a lot of them yeah my
counsellor in high school when I told
her that I wanted to go to North
Carolina or you see all these places she
was like your GPA doesn't indicate house
goes no no I'm gonna go to UCLA that I'm
gonna go you know like hey I was talking
about thirty [ __ ] game yeah exactly
but I was just like you know to the
point like there's there's you know we
talked about the the parenting and and
you know some of them are just [ __ ]
setting the kids up here failure it's
like
practical optimism is amazing yes
everything else sucks pessimist sucks
delusion suck what instead of just
saying that once you say okay now show
me the tool show me the way in order to
get to that job do you what do I need to
chase yourself up like if I asked you
that question how do you go with that
I'm that again I said if I ask you do
you beat yourself up right like
something happens that you're the one
beating yourself up is that like part of
your framework yeah I definitely do that
I would say like just calm I just get
really I definitely beat myself up for
sure I've just been spending so much
time like with myself it's why nobody's
really seen any content about it cuz
again because of what's going on with me
I want to be very careful to stay in my
lane and not overstep but it's just you
know I got nothing else to say other
than man I just want to say one thing I
got so much love for you please
understand that the voice that beat
yourself up I genuinely believe this I
really don't think it's your voice I
think it's a voice that's been input and
I think once you understand that it
liberate cyou when you start realizing
you're not the person booing yourself
and if you can figure that part out if
that could start the part of a thesis or
something that you discover I think you
could be liberating in a way that you
can't believe what that will do for you
bro yeah and to know that you're not
alone to like I you know I think it's
predisposition like we're all taught
early on when we start speaking and
start you know absorbing what our
parents are saying are people around us
are saying we we're kind of taught how
to think and that voice in your head
that narrative that me can really [ __ ]
you up real quick really quick so until
you start doing that doing that work and
then continue because you can have it's
like related to basketball you can have
a great game and that feeling only lasts
for 24 to 48 hours whereas you have a
terrible game it's a national TV game
and you feel like you're set up for
failure that's gonna like that could
last for two weeks
that's just how that's how negative
thoughts are and I'm also trying to
think about how to turn it into positive
because like one of the things that's
really interesting about me is I do not
smell roses so like like like back to
the Yankees in the and the Rangers I
dropped them the second after the
championship like you know like I'm
trying to think about why I talk about
process a lot of times is like like to
your
point the national the national
televised game like it's not that I'd
well about it I don't know there's
something I've been thinking a lot about
lately which is like with everything
that's going on with me I talk a lot
about not hearing the boos I don't give
a [ __ ] what you think but it goes both
ways I also don't hear the accolades
like so many people as my notoriety and
awareness grows and things that are
going on with me there was like man
you're so humble and every time I hear
somebody say that I say it's because I
can't hear your boos that is literally
what happens when somebody you know cuz
they don't expect it especially the way
I am on video and on stage they get
confused by like the humility when they
actually get to know me sure and I'm
like and it's so funny how intuitive I
feel that's completely laddered to me
not hearing people that [ __ ] on me like
I don't get high when they cheer and I
don't get like loves we say in ambi I
fail quickly quickly but it's also
having success quickly as well like as a
few million a gap I wish you well bro
really thanks for calling one of my
favorite things in the world of sports
that maps to life is when the home team
boozed the home team after the road team
went on a Lebanon run and you call a
timeout and I've been thinking about
this for two years I don't know what it
is about that singular moment and all
the sports I watch you know like I love
box of one of my favorite fighters of
all time just passed away got hit by a
car you know Sweet Pea Whitaker you know
Pernell Whitaker I don't know if you
know that name and I loved him for
defense he was Mayweather before and
Mayweather in the events and I'm a
counter puncher as a businessman so I
associate with him and that would be
like the Tyson Fury I get it he has a
great story to Tyson if you're listening
hit me up uh I don't know what it is
about the home team letting the road
team go on a levee no run timeout and
the whole [ __ ] place every even like
the best teams like by the way
ironically back to a meta story I went
to the Knicks Cavs opener when LeBron
came back yeah best talked so being in
that game right obviously I'll hit that
yeah left wing yes so like yeah you know
even like all the [ __ ] accolades and
bronze back in that game it's the first
game back what's euphoria Knicks going
like a seven Oh Ron
I'm out and I sit there and I'm like
there is something about this home back
to how I think about it's fragile
it's what have you done for me lately
that's it's like it also makes me want
people to think about life that way
which is like you could have a shitty
three years and it's still just a second
quarter yeah
life just went on a 7o run on you like
what's the score at triple zero all
right I don't know there's an I mean
Bulls who I hate with all my heart some
of those Road Nick games that I went to
back in a day like for [ __ ] shame 360
beach if they give these [ __ ] down
1302 start thinking boo and I'm like
[ __ ] and there's something about like
how I think about that how I think you
know watching Wimbledon the other day
Joker
I'm like well nothing Joker's by far my
favorite tennis player by far so I'm in
this bar as the matches in the fifth set
and the whole bar is going nuts for
Federer of course and joke and I'm
sitting there watching rooting for Joker
quietly because I'm with the fam and I'm
trying not to make attention like try
say private and Joker that nine-minute
game where Federal's came back from
40-love Joker breaks through and wins it
and I go nuts
bars looks in there the whole bar looks
at me and then like two guys laughed and
they came up to me like you're not
really rooting for Joker you're just
doing that like literally verbatim asked
me if I just did that for show I said
I'm looking for [ __ ] Joker and and
there's and Joker I think at his best is
when he takes on the role of the villain
right because he's trying to embrace he
wants to be well liked of course it's
got [ __ ] [ __ ] Nadal and Federer
loved so mother there's no way there's
no way you're never gonna win he is
gonna win that game I'll tell you what
when he's old when they're gone sure
he's the old man because they feel like
nah hundred-person the same way I feel
about like Kobe I hated him my whole
career like his whole career until when
I felt he lost a little bit of a stab
sure I'm like okay now I want him to
like you know like it's what America
does rise crash right you know so and
I'm all underdog but like the face he
made like nothing speaks to me more than
Joker's face when he [ __ ] is in that
match the whole world [ __ ] the audience
at Wimbledon is rooting again
Tim and he looks at everybody and says
[ __ ] you I love that
I agree that he has to take on that Phil
and role i watching beck again
potentially could get him the most
Majors ever i fully believe it yeah and
it's not natural because what happens
when those two guys are out absolutely
this orb set and takes it on he you know
what the breakthrough of his career from
my perspective was was at the US Open I
don't know if you know this reference
where he was in deep [ __ ] it was over
Federer was serving for the match and he
returned this one forehand which was
like such a rock you forehand that kind
of [ __ ] everyone's psyche announcers
the stadium and ultimately Federer in my
opinion and he came all the way back and
won and that's when I was like I do
remember I actually watch a lot of
tennis I respect I'm not I'm not the
biggest rehabs last year and we became
friendly and it was like a tight little
game and like like just like watching
you down in the last two minutes and we
were having a little banter and you're
like like the Knicks came back and like
tied or something and it you looked at
me and said no don't worry this is
they're not going to win I was so pumped
I still hated you yeah like I was like a
[ __ ] you dude but like but like I loved
it cuz that's exactly what I live for
that to him trying to figure out how to
take that negativity and turn it into
that versus what Gavin's talk like I
will probably spend my whole life trying
to figure out how to communicate around
the whole world wants to take a [ __ ] on
you and you take that and make it a
positive is obviously a foundation of
self esteem lack of insecurity many
other things I gotta figure it out
because somewhere in there and I think
it's a very fine line you know that to
me is the [ __ ] game but that also
requires when everybody tells you you're
awesome
to know it but not fully embrace it
because then you're fully embracing the
booze to I think a lot of kids that are
getting delusional with their parents or
getting a lot of success early are stuck
late that's why school [ __ ] people up
you're a straight-a student and you
think that's life and then life kicks in
and life laughs right well there's no
diversity it's one system
yeah life authority that that cutter and
somehow I just said it but nobody else
did
yeah no I get it thank you bro
appreciate it bro thank you thank you I
was [ __ ] awesome let's just end it
with that cool